each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
a good morning everyone welcome my name
is Karen strands and I'm a researcher
here at Microsoft Research and today
it's my pleasure to introduce dr. John
cumbers John is the founder of st.
symbiote beta which is a community of
people and companies startup companies
around synthetic biology John has also a
pretty interesting background his has an
undergrad in computer science of masters
in bioinformatics and a PhD in molecular
biology from Brown University and John
today is going to talk about the scene
in the synthetic biology industry so
welcome to him thank you hi everyone
thanks for having me Karen thanks for
inviting me it was a short flight up
from from mountain view this morning I
live in the heart of Silicon Valley and
I I've worked at NASA for the last seven
years that's what brought me to Silicon
Valley at NASA Ames right next to
Microsoft actually in Silicon Valley but
after living in Silicon Valley for a few
years the startup culture rubs off on
you and so I started a start-up myself
and like most startups if it failed
pretty quickly but and so I went back to
NASA but I felt so so restricted after
after working in a start-up all the
adrenaline rushing through your blood
being able to do whatever you want hi
whoever you want buy whatever you want
and then back to NASA where you have to
fill out all these forms to to hire
people to buy things or two to use your
credit card even so so I went back to
NASA but I only went back four days a
week and on on fridays i started what is
now sin x 0 beta and simba beta is this
activity hub for synthetic biology
startup companies investors thought
leaders and as the industry is matured
and I'll show you how its maturing with
some charts shortly it's now a community
for the for the whole synthetic biology
industry and we run conferences that's
what we started off doing and we had one
just last week in San Francisco and
particularly the theme of this
conference was was where tech needs
biotech and so you'll probably recognize
some of the speakers from the tech world
on the slide behind me people like Tim
O'Reilly was one of the keynote speakers
Sam Altman the president of Y Combinator
along with some of the biggest names in
the synthetic biology industry RJ Kirk
is the CEO of in tracks on the biggest
synthetic biology company out there with
a market cap of four and a half billion
dollars and jason kelly one of the new
startups in the field called ginkgo
buyer works which recently recently
raised 45 million dollars in a in a
series a so we bring together the
community a couple of times a year once
in San Francisco once in London that's
how we started as a conference it's now
my full-time gig I left NASA just last
month and we also do courses training
and we ran a company database keeping
track of who's investing in what who's
doing what and how the industry is
growing so I'm going to talk today about
what synthetic biology is give you a
quick introduction talk about some of
the trends in the industry that we've
been tracking and that we see and then
talk about some of the companies that
are in the industry and what they're
doing before I do that I don't know
who's in the audience so could you put
your hand up if you could tell me and
I'm not going to ask you to do it I just
want to know whether you could tell me
how a gene relates to a protein so put
your hand up if you've got a good
understanding of how gene relates to a
protein and that's about a good a good
kind of 50-50 mix do we know how many
people we've got online okay well if
anyone online has a question or if any
of you have a question throughout then
please stop and ask because as a former
computer scientist I know the pain of
the jargon that we have in in biology
and how complicated it is and I didn't
know how a gene related to a protein 11
years ago when I made the switch from
computer science in Dubai informatics
and then into into a PhD in cell
molecular biology so what is synthetic
biology well you could argue
that synthetic DNA is a big part of
synthetic biology this is the birth of
Genentech now multi-billion dollar
company based in South San Francisco the
birthplace of biotechnology and on the
blackboard behind the two founders of
Genentech you can see a few a few things
that are critical to to the industry one
is I think I don't need the pointer
anyway it is okay great thanks for just
not pressing hard enough so you can see
synthetic DNA up on the up on the
chalkboard here you can see a plasmid
well which is a circular piece of DNA
and you can see a E coli cell up here
and these three things combined into
this into this plasmid here and this is
now the birth of biotechnology here it's
it's taking a cell a bacterial a chassis
capable of producing things and it's
taking a gene of interest such as this
piece of DNA which encodes for something
interesting and it's putting it onto
another piece of DNA and putting it
inside a cell so this is this is really
genetic engineering this is what we've
been doing for the last 30-some years is
taking pieces of DNA that exist in
nature putting them into a plasmid and
building that plasmid up into a into a
cell and once you've done that you can
then start to use technologies such as
fermentation which we've been making
alcohol and wine another and other
enzymes or or products and then growing
up that organism and producing whatever
protein is made from that from that DNA
and this was the first thing that that
Genentech produced it was a small
peptide a small protein of amino acids
linked together and it was insulin and
so in the past diabetics would get their
insulin from slaughtering pigs taking
the pancreas from pigs and cows and
slaughtering it and using it as human
insulin now in the future you have
humulin human insulin which is
recombinant and so it takes the DNA
directly from your own insulin or human
insulin and it slides slices it splices
it into a plasmid and boots up that
plasmid so that you can brew drugs just
like you might brew alcohol and that's
the small peptide insulin hugely
successful the birth of biotechnology
and now a multi-billion dollar industry
that we have but that's not all biology
can make what what could we produce with
the with these things Chris actually it
is yet hops barley water there's one
thing missing in the production of beer
which is the yeast and that's not really
put on the label but it's the most
important thing and there's a wonderful
place in san diego called white labs and
if your home brewer you probably know
white labs they sell many different
kinds of yeast and if you go to the the
tasting room at White Labs you can order
a flight of beer but there's something
different about that flight of beer it's
exactly the same ingredients that goes
into every beer but they just changed
the yeast that's used to do the
fermentation to make the alcohol and
it's it's five completely different
tasting beers demonstrating that the
power of biology for for making making
things you can use exactly the same
inputs and get five different outputs
based on the strain of yeast and so you
can also make these wonderful flavors
such as cheese and you can also make
food does anyone know or does any want
to guess what this might be growing in
Hawaii it's spirulina right so if you've
heard of if you've seen it in the health
food so it's this spiral shaped bacteria
it's a complete protein source and you
can buy it and it's grown in large pools
in Hawaii but it's actually
single-celled bacteria rather
than any crops this is Romanesco
broccoli something that looks absolutely
beautiful it also tastes tastes great
and it just shows the power of biology
as a manufacturing technology as does
bread we you would think that there's
this amazing property of of using yeast
in bread something to do with the flavor
or the the enzymes that it produces but
it's actually not Brett that you use
yeast in bread because it provides gas
inside as you're cooking and it has this
then wonderful spongy texture so it's
not to do with the taste or the flavor
but actually the texture and if you if
you look around you on the beach you see
these these wonderful things not just
soft biological gooey green gooey things
but these amazing shells that you can
see for building structure and if you go
into a redwood forest you can also see
these these phenomenal structures that
are over 200 years old and dwarf in
comparison to the person sitting next to
them and this is an example of an
engineered system that was built out of
mushroom bricks for the museum about not
and not just structural things but also
things that smell good like this rose
and there's a one of the company's
ginkgo by works is producing this rose
scented perfume so all this is to try to
demonstrate to you the power of biology
it's this versatile manufacturing
technology for producing many different
kinds of products but above all it's a
manufacturing technology and so how
genes relate to the proteins which was
the first question that I asked you is
that you have AC T's and G's on us on a
double helix of DNA and through this
wonderful mechanism of transcription and
translation which I'll show you a video
of in a second you have these amazing
structures such as these proteins
produced on the left hand side and many
of the things that you see around in
nature or that you eat or that do things
are proteins and proteins are replicated
inside of cells which themselves are
self replica
so a single cell can divide in 20
minutes if it's a bacterial cell or a
bit longer if it's a mammalian cell so
you have all the self-replicating
machinery going on for the production of
cells and then for the production of
proteins and enzymes that are made from
those cells and then we'll packaged up
inside a nucleus if it's a if it's a
mammalian cell into your chromosomes
which you're familiar with terms of the
23 pairs that you have all this
information packaged up for the
production of stuff and this is what's
actually going on inside your cells this
is a RNA polymerase molecule this is
running along a piece of DNA and it's
actually reading the code and what we're
seeing here we're about to see is the
conversion of DNA into RNA and into
protein and that's called the central
dogma of molecular biology and in any
second now the machinery is going to
bind on this is the RNA polymerase
machinery and it's going to start
whizzing along reading it and this is an
animation but it's in real time and you
can see the the ability of this enzyme
to run along the DNA there it goes
producing just like a ticker tape coming
out the other side this strand of RNA
and these yellow molecules that are
flying around these are also a C's T's
and G's with some exceptions for RNA but
in general you can now see that why I'm
saying this is a manufacturing
technology because you can see these
this ticker tape coming out the back the
DNA is being read and that's in the red
color and the RNA is being produced and
that's in the yellow color and so all
this has been discovered over the last
20 years or so is what this machinery is
how it works and how we can use
engineered biology as this manufacturing
base
for the production of many different
things such as I shown in the previous
slides and the the the two technologies
which I think are really important for
synthetic biologists one is in the
reading of DNA that is sequencing of DNA
and you can sequence your genome for
about a thousand dollars now it costs
about a billion dollars or more ten
years ago and then the storage of that
sequence information in a computational
for more inner in a data form and then
the the synthesis part which is then the
writing of DNA which allows us to write
anything that we want to write and put
it back inside a cell so what is
synthetic biology synthetic biology is
trying to make biology easy to engineer
so it's not necessarily a core
technology it's definitely those two
technologies of reading and writing DNA
but fundamentally it's a community of
people who want to see a very different
biological future than the one that we
that we have now and it's a bunch of
Engineers coming into the field of
biology and trying to understand how we
can engineer biology I I think it's a
little akin to web 1.0 and web two point
oh but when web two point O came about
there was a huge flurry of activity a
lot of excitement a new generation of
people coming into the field a new
generation of investors backing
companies and startups in this field and
a new generation of products that we see
now such as flickr and twitter and
facebook but there was also a bunch of
people who said hey what is this web two
point oh there's nothing you know
there's nothing to it we've been doing
that since since the beginning you get
similar thing with synthetic biology
it's built on the foundations of genetic
engineering but there's a number of
people who say well there's no really
new technology it's kind of just built
on what we've been doing all along and
I'll show you some of those technologies
and then the dates of those technologies
which aren't really new so this I think
some truth to that but there was one
wonderful quote which was in nature
biotechnology a few years ago which I
think sums up the field very well I'm
not going to read it but it talks about
the principles of engineering and the
difference between science and
engineering and a lot of a lot of
scientific principles are underlying
synthetic biology but it's really the
engineering and the engineers coming
into the field of biology which are now
trying to make advances in our ability
to make things and the so that the quote
talks about the Wright brothers and how
they didn't they didn't invent flight
they didn't invent an aeroplane by
understanding the principles of
aerodynamics instead they understood
enough to fly a plane and to have a
short repeatability cycle and
engineering cycle so that they could fly
many planes and learn from all the ones
that crashed after after a few years
they suddenly had a plane that would
that could fly but only only years later
did scientists understand the principles
of aerodynamics that that they
understood how the plane fly how the
plane flew and I think we're in a
similar position with biology we've got
a lot of scientific underpinning that
can understand the the principles of of
molecular biology but we're really going
to make great advances when we tried to
design things with biology and build
things with biology and later on the
science will catch up with the things
that we've managed to build and my
favorite quote which I think predicts
the some of the trends that are coming
is by craig Venter one of the pioneers
in the field who says over the next 20
years synthetic genomics is going to
become the standard for making anything
so I'm going to move on to some of the
trends that we see coming but I just
want to pause in case there's any
questions on anything that I said so far
okay great
so if you look back at the core
technologies that I talked about the
discovery of DNA in 1953 that it is a
double helix the first the string of
synthetic nucleotides a C's T's and G's
that was strung together 1972 and the
first reading of DNA in terms of the
mass acceptance of reading DNA Sanger
sequencing in 1975 you do debating my my
dates roast DNA on for ros-lehtinen ouch
that's a big faux pas I'm sorry so Rob
saying I have the twister in left-handed
twist instead of right-handed twist so
I'll fix that oh sure i'll go back to
the the person who did it for over here
so so i think that we're at the start of
a fifth Industrial Revolution so we've
we've gone through water and steam
electricity automation in terms of IT
systems I think we're currently in
Internet of Things and a cloud
revolution cloud computing and I think
the next one is is the bio industrial
revolution food synthesis and sequencing
and the predictable engineering of
biology and this chart is is taken from
Rob Carson who I'm sure if you don't
know you should you should get to know
him is at the back of the room the
economist coin Rob's Rob's data the the
Carlson curve the equivalent of Moore's
law for biology which shows obviously
you're familiar with Moore's law they
the doubling of the number of
microprocessor of chips on a sorry of
transistors on a microprocessor Rob
started to see this this prediction in
the falling cost of DNA sequencing and
the falling cost of DNA synthesis so you
can see right reading dnas on the red
line there and writing DNA is on the
green the green line and we've actually
dropped faster than Moore's law at about
this rate because this is a log scale
and we were dropping faster than Moore's
law here in the red
and it's becoming rapidly cheaper to
synthesize DNA that is to write DNA and
it's already vastly cheaper to read DNA
that is to sequence it yeah well it
flattens because it's it's practically
you know it's extremely cheap at the
moment so it wouldn't you know it's I
mean it's already extremely cheap so
could it could it get much cheaper well
so there's a in principle there's
another point on there that's an order
of magnitude lower and maybe it's
picking up again it's it's not just
about technology it's about the
economics in the markets and alumina cup
cause basically that crash in the price
starting in 2004 with new technologies
and then now they dominate your market
and they have no reason to lower the
price so it's not as if it's not the
simple story as it might be with chips
even though that story's more complex
this is jon's talk so i'll shut up so I
just repeated for people evening online
so Rob saying alumina came in here
brought the price down rapidly and then
there's little competition or incentive
to bring the price down further at the
moment but so it could go it could go
down further and I don't know if anybody
saw this paper it was by Charles cookout
Charlie cockles lab at Edinburgh
University it came out in june and i
found it randomly through a google
search for something else and i really
thought it was wonderful it was
calculating the number of base pairs of
DNA on the planet and they calculated
five point three times ten to the 31
million bases of DNA on the planet and
then they came up with this this
operations per second on nucleotide
operations and compared it to the number
of supercomputers that it would be today
if you if you treated the whole planet
and the number of DNA bases as a
computational
problem or as a composer as a as an
operating system showing the equivalent
of 10 to the 21 supercomputers so it's a
wonderful paper and I think it if you
start to take a step back and look at
this ecosystem of DNA and everything is
is programming and chugging along just
as that video that I showed you that's
for a single gene in a single cell and
my body has a hundred trillion cells and
each of those hundred trillion cells has
20,000 genes and each gene could be
transcribed they could be multiple well
there are multiple copies so just inside
me at the moment is an incredible
biological computing platform not my
brain but just the DNA itself so it's a
fantastic paper and maybe that somebody
you want to invite to to talk to your to
your group in the future your checkers
going to the galaxy hypothesis of the
meaning of the earth the earth is a
giant supercomputer designed to answer
the question okay you know where I'm
going so the answer is 42 the answer is
42 what is the question exactly and so
now I'm going to talk a little bit about
some of the funding trends and what's
going on in the industry and this is
actually before we dive into the
industry this is federally funded
research for synthetic biology between
08 and 2014 it's about eight hundred and
twenty twenty million dollars so it's
been an initiative of the US government
synthetic biology in terms of funding
the engineering of biology and and
that's because it's an extremely
important area of the economy and this
is also some of Rob's data that he gave
to a Senate briefing in 2013 looking at
the this is 2012 data the total revenue
from genetically modified system is 353
billion dollars in the US and a nice
comparison is if you compare it with the
worldwide semiconductor revenue for 2012
which was about 300
three billion so it just shows you the
power of genetic engineering and genetic
modification and his roughly its split
between crops industrials such as
chemicals and materials and biologics of
drugs then if you look at a couple of
other trends this is I gin the
International genetically engineered
machines competition this is the first
robotics for synthetic biology so if
you're familiar with the robotics
competition this is the equivalent for
genetic engineering and it's phenomenal
and the reason I put this slide in is
because Microsoft funded this back in
2003 they Microsoft gave MIT a whole
bunch of money for interesting projects
and one of the projects that was funded
out of that was the iGEM competition it
wasn't called I gem at the time but a
Microsoft dabbled in synthetic biology
for a few years funding some various
things I was at a conference here in
fact Chris maybe did we meet then in ya
back in 2009 at the University of
Washington 2008 about standards for
synthetic biology that's where the
synthetic biology language came from s
bowl and a number of other things and
when you look at the ident eames
worldwide there's over 250 of them a
quarter of them are in China and a huge
growth in the number of teams
year-on-year it's a lot of fun and
there's a U dub thing that does really
well every year as well then when you
look at the academic publications it's
also going exponential in terms of the
number of people to publishing about
synthetic biology and then when you look
at the number of companies in the
industry that's also growing and you can
see there are over 200 companies that
self-identify as synthetic biology
company's growing at about 20 20 or 25 a
year and we track all this in our
company database in 2015 alone there's
been over half a billion dollars
invested in from venture money in
synthetic biology companies and that
number of companies is growing and the
amount that's being funded
being put into those companies is also
growing Y Combinator's got interested in
this this is the early-stage seed
funding based in Silicon Valley twenty
percent of their companies are now
biotech companies ten percent are
synthetic biology companies there's also
in de Bayeux another accelerator in San
Francisco and a branch that they have in
Cork and island as well and what's
notable is a lot of the new money that's
coming into these companies a big
portion of that half a billion dollars
is coming from tech entrepreneurs so
Bill Gates invested in the Edit s
medicine round Tim O'Reilly as I talked
about earlier has been investing in in
Griffin Y Combinator's funded a whole
whole number of these and Eric Schmidt
through his innovation endeavors fund
and and some of the paypal founders such
as Peter Thiel but also you see paypal
yahoo Netscape Twitter a lot of these
are tech companies now getting into
biotech it's exactly I mean you could so
the question was where do I draw the
line between between biotech and
synthetic biology and it's about the
same line that I draw between web 1.0
and web two point oh so I think it's
pretty difficult to define and that's
why I made a point of saying that the
company's self-identified synthetic
biology companies because I see it more
as a movement of people who want to
rationally engineer biology and make it
predictable and a lot of the people in
biotechnology I'm more focused on the
application rather than the process that
they going through so it's a good
question and I'm kind of dodging it but
I'm going to give you some examples of
the of the companies that are working in
this area and this this is something we
call the synthetic biology stack and
it's just a grouping of the companies
that are in the industry and it's a nice
way to think about it I'm just going to
pause any other questions before I dive
into the the third part so the synthetic
biology stack starts at the base with
gene and genome synthesis that is
synthesizing a C's T's and G's and there
are whole number companies who are
making synthetic DNA so there's a a yeah
blue heron was a Seattle company it was
purchased by origene great and then was
origin purchased by somebody else
recently was origin still origin in
Seattle no so blue heron was one of the
early companies in synthetic DNA based
here in Seattle but you can see there's
origin here a lot of these are in the
Bay Area or Massachusetts so a large
number companies working in this area
and it's fast becoming a commodity
business the synthesizer make DNA and as
I said earlier the prices falling the
basic principle are you can make challah
go smalls strings of accts geez
chip-based synthesis which then
synthesizes these on top of the
substrate and then assembly technology
which then aligns these sequences
together into longer strand this is one
of the new entrance to the market Emily
the post from twist they've raised of 80
million dollars and a new technology
based on silicon rather than glass for
synthesizing the DNA lab genius one of
the companies from the UK is making
synthetic DNA libraries that's very
diverse strings of DNA which are used
for many different applications and sim
promix a Scottish company that is making
synthetic promoters that is promoters
are the short pieces of DNA at the
beginning of a gene to turn it on or off
and they're using bioinformatics
approaches where all of this
sequence information that we've been
storing in databases for the last decade
they're now using search algorithms to
find the genes find the area before the
gene that is a promoter that turns it on
or off and then pulling them all out and
then making customized promoters so you
can turn on and off different genes that
will organism this is only for
eukaryotic cells at the moment so it
doesn't work in bacteria this particular
algorithm and I don't know any I don't
know any more details than that but
there are different there's different
machinery used for bacterias for
eukaryotes a DNA to point o down in
Menlo Park they do machine learning for
protein optimization and i'll come back
to machine learning algorithms in a
second but also doing a lot of DNA
synthesis themselves so next up as we go
up this stack and these all build on
each other until we get to the
applications at the top are the CAD
tools for gene and genome design and you
can see a number of the different
companies there are a lot of companies
in this space because it's relatively
cheap to get into compared to doing wet
lab biology and so just a few of these
bench Ling which was recently funded by
andreessen horowitz for for doing DNA
editing and analysis in the cloud a very
nice tool for for for doing that desktop
genetics which has a platform for
crisper genome editing crisper you
probably read about in the mainstream
press it's a it's a very exciting
technology that allows you to to edit
cells in vivo that is I don't need to go
through the process of purifying DNA
editing DNA putting DNA back into a cell
replicating cell instead I can literally
inject and inject crisper cast nine into
my into
into my leg if I find what it should do
that and edit the cells directly in my
leg and there's been experiments of
being able to cure paralysis in in
rodent legs by injecting this this this
crisper into it it was invented three
years ago or discovered three years ago
it's a natural mechanism and it's from
the in the four years that we've been
running the conference from having no
crisper talks to about fifty percent
crisper talks to know about probably
eighty percent crisper talks everyone's
doing crisper and it's extremely
exciting to see us speeding up the
design build and test cycle in in
biology and at Microsoft Research Andrew
Phillips who many of you will be
familiar with is looking at modeling and
coming up with a programming language
and tools for simulating and analyzing
models of complex biological systems so
more systems biology the synthetic
biology but definitely some great work
going on in the UK a Microsoft Research
their own and riffin is a is a new
company founded two years ago and
riffing is a platform technology for
cloud analytics of lab data so it feeds
in a lot of different data from from the
lab and has a platform for analyzing
that this is a fairly new area cloud
labs and automation cloud labs is just
like Azure or AWS or Google come and
what Google's platform is cool but
Google whatever that company's platform
is called and this is really exciting
because the same things happening to
biology instead of having mainframe
instead of having expensive lab
equipment in your own lab you can now
rent out lab equipment in somebody
else's lab so there are two companies
that are doing that emerald therapeutics
and transcript check and they have
automated labs and you can use an API
for
for using those those pieces of
equipments those pieces of equipment in
their lap so you can send them samples
you can put it in their machines they
will run your script that you've written
and send you back either the data or the
sample you don't need to own a lab and
we're calling this virtual bio the idea
that you don't need a expensive lab
anymore or even a lab at all to have a
biotech startup general eiling's five
points depending on if you have
different experiments they don't have
the equipment you can't do it so how
complete in general or are these
platforms sure so the question is how
complete other platforms I think it's
pretty I mean transcript dick has I I
think the answer is you know the
forefront of biology is the forefront of
science is always bleeding edge so the
labs you're always going to get somebody
trying to come up with a new essay or a
new way of doing something or inventing
a new piece of equipment to solve the
question that they're trying to answer
so it's difficult to say how you know on
a scale of how complete they are I think
for all standard molecular biology
procedures such as purifying DNA
extraction growth mixing an analysis I
think 100% then when you start moving to
new things that they're constantly
playing catch-up but I think it's pretty
good one thing that we're doing and I'll
come under this in a second is a is a
competition called blue sky bio where
we're giving out resources to startups
to have them come up with new ideas of
startups that they can do relying on
technologies like this and so for an
academic pursued it's made it that it
will be limited because you're at the
edge of the envelope in terms of what
you're trying to come up with but for a
startup that you're doing you could you
could view it as a different problem i
have these resources available to me and
what problem can i answer
what so that I don't need a lab so I
think it's a different kind of
experiment different kind of question
you do yeah and emerald therapeutics I
think more focusing on the analytics
side in terms of drug development and an
analysis yes so for these kind of
experiments how long do to the blue team
how long would the experiment take it
depends you could do a bacterial growth
curve looking at how fast bacteria grow
in just a few hours if it's not a if
it's something faster than that let's
say a light SI where you're looking at
the production of light it could be just
a few seconds so oh it could be if it's
a slow-growing bacterium it could be
weeks and there are different business
models for how you pay for these
products as well whether they're per
hour there are a subscription model so
and then so I've got automation
companies on here as well you've got
companies that are looking at
automationDirect weight around using
sound so if if you've been in a
molecular biology lab any time in the
last hundred years or 50 years you you
know there's a lot of pipetting a lot of
moving of liquid a lot of repetition so
you're hiring the you know the smartest
people in the world to to stand at a lab
bench and and concentrate on a
repetitive task for 46 years of a PhD
it's not it's not the most productive
use of time so there you know I think
this is a huge area for growth in terms
of the ability to automate a lot of this
and is it Eric Flavin's that you dab
who's got this is Aquarius his work
aquarium his his company's well worth a
visit I haven't been there but I hear it
sir it's a it's really interesting
so yeah so a lot of these companies
working on automation and glamour so
this is trans cryptic that I mentioned
just now and they've been funded about
14 and a half million dollars and really
looking at lowering costs increasing
precision and allowing you to automate a
lot of these tasks this is a really
interesting company in the UK that
allowing you to do tens of millions of
cells at a time and analyzing them using
mass spec so the moment mass
spectrometer is very expensive for
looking at the Mark V the atoms that are
inside a sample this can do tens of
millions of cells vastly faster and
cheaper than anything that's out there
so then as we move up more towards the
biology and less away from the tools we
see organism engineering platforms that
means you've created an organism or a
set of organisms or a set of tools and
you're able to use these organisms for
producing many different things so
there's number of companies in this area
so ginko by works is one of the one of
the early companies and this was the
first company that Y Combinator funded
so they have a platform for
high-throughput automation of strain
engineering so if you want to produce a
yeast cell that has a particular smell
characteristic because you're producing
a perfume then you can give your strain
to them and they would ramp up the
production of that particular molecule
or they will design the organism for you
if you have some new fragrance that you
want to design or a food product or a
material project product zymogens in a
similar category to that zaida which is
here in seattle is doing similarly using
a big data platform and machine learning
to to optimize the production of
pharmaceuticals synthase is a company
that's based in the UK the day instead
of taking in the organism in house they
will sell a complete system and to end
for a
company that might want to have an
automated system for the production of
whatever the company is producing an
anther is a new programming language
they've produced for engineering or
biology and this is that Tim fell who's
the CEO zymogen who recently raised 44
million in a series a a very similar
business model to ginkgo that I
mentioned just a second ago and working
in chemicals pharmaceuticals and food
and then right at the top layer we have
the application so the lines kind of
blurred between the platforms and the
applications because some companies make
both but you can see a lot of the
interesting applications a lot of the
crisper companies that I just mentioned
that tool for in vivo editing such as
Intel yeah or editors or crispa
therapeutics or caribou but then also
some of the more interesting
applications are things like bolt
threads which is a spider silk this is
Dan Whitmire who's the CEO you might
have seen that north face jacket that
just came out last week made of spider
silk that's a competitor to to these
folks they've raised 40 million dollars
to date and they've taken the genes from
the spider and they've put them into
bacteria or yeast and they are now able
to spin a spider silk just like you
might grow yeast for production of
alcohol then I'm able to grow spider
silk instead of alcohol or a mixture of
I'm joking so really interesting
performance properties of these fabrics
because they were able to engineer the
DNA an engineer then the property of the
material that are producing this is a
French company called eligor bioscience
they're actually doing engineer
probiotics you've heard of probiotics in
yogurt and things to help keep your gut
in good shape their engineering those
organisms for particular health
properties
another French company Thomas land rain
is making the first renewable inks that
is things for dyeing materials which is
a very damaging process to the
environment the whole process for
producing inks and bio-based solutions
can be much more sustainable non-toxic
and recyclable as well and RZ de that I
mentioned earlier who has this
computational platform for metabolic
engineering and they're particularly
working in drugs and pharmaceuticals and
they're based here in Seattle I wanted
to touch on big data and machine
learning because this was the session
that Andrew Phillips chaired at our
conference just last week and we we had
a giant competition this was the
giveaway that I mentioned this blue sky
by our competition and Microsoft was a
sponsor this competition so we gave out
cloud computing as your time to to the
winner of the competition which was
caliber bioscience and caliber is based
down in San Diego and he will s is the
founder and they're also making an
engineered probiotic strain of yoga so
the idea is that one of the cures for
depression or one of the treatments for
depression is is tryptophan a particular
amino acid but if you it's known to cure
depression but if you you have to eat a
huge amount of tryptophan in order to do
that so he was idea was to produce a
yogurt that had this probiotic strain in
it that would produce higher levels of
tryptophan so you could eat your yogurt
for breakfast and it would contain this
probiotic this has never been shown
before never never gone through approval
for this kind of medicine where you're
actually eating at the the organism
that's producing the drug but I think
we're going to see a lot more of it
because we have more bacterial cells in
your gut than you do human cells in your
body by many times over
so we're starting to understand and work
with the organisms that are living with
us rather than trying to kill them all
with antibiotics and in particular she
was using these modeling tools and data
analytics to try to find the proteins
that she could express or the second is
she could bill for the tryptophan
production and she gave this wonderful
talk where she really outline the
problems in machine learning that you
can solve using synthetic biology which
I thought might be of interest to to you
folks how to optimize promoters and
pathways we talked about that how can we
design these various things either a
promoter which was what the Scottish
company sim promix was doing or a
pathway which she's doing for tryptophan
production trying to understand which
genes are essential or which can be used
for fermentation on different scales and
the errors that she thought were
interesting for the future was for gene
discovery understanding which hosts
could be used for the production of
different things that is which organism
maybe yeast or bacteria or different
kinds of yeast or bacteria and then
which drugs could be used for different
patients so she gave a really good talk
outlining the the different options for
that so I wanted just to wrap up and
talk about a couple of events that we've
got coming up coming up next year one
we're doing a big event in london in the
beginning of april and we've been doing
an event in london for four years and
then with our first event in china will
be in june 2016 really trying to
understand what's going on in China and
organize a tour of synthetic biology
companies there if you're interested in
learning more we do take we do do
courses in synthetic biology and we send
out a weekly email news is about who's
doing what and who's getting funded and
what products that are available and
with that I'll thank you for listening
and taking
questions yeah at one time of sort of
safety in the industry I remember the
IGM conference was a lot of controversy
about you know just turning all these
people lose with these tools with it was
a big issue are people still worried
about it or is it that we just sort of
all groan it at this point with what's
the current phone thank you that's a
good question about safety in the
industry and I think the biggest fear
was that if you give anybody access to
these tools then anybody could create a
biological weapon in their basement or
anybody could kill somebody and I think
I James done a really good job of
building in bio safety into the
educational curriculum and I think it's
a much more practical training and
safety than you might get just through
following some regimented thing at a
university so I think safety from that
regard I think is it certainly not
forgotten its front and center of the
competition still and it's taught on in
every undergraduate team I think in
terms of the you know will people create
create nasty strains to create bio
weapons and things like that in their
basements I think potentially but with
every technology there comes from an
engineering point of view a
responsibility to do good with the
technology and there's the potential to
do bad with it as well and you can you
could cultivate anthrax from from soil
I'm sure hearing in Seattle without
needing to go to the extent of trying to
genetic engineer something and anthrax
is pretty bad so I think with the
knowledge that's out there you can
already do pretty nasty things so I
think what the field has done is to grow
this pool of responsible use and people
who think smart about what they can do
with the technology and what they want
to do with the technology
questions all right let's thank John
again